welcome to the iced coffee hour my name
is Layla formosi and over the last two
years this podcast has made over 2
million in revenue from AdSense I wish
that's close that would be really nice
what's the number gram 239
000 oh wow yeah yeah but great guess
nonetheless thank you so much for coming
on Layla we got a lot to get into and uh
people may recognize your last name
hormozi we had an Alex twice previously
and I got really excited to have you on
because someone told me I don't remember
exactly what it was
um it was a business person entrepreneur
person they said Layla hormozi is a
savant in Business and Entrepreneurship
they said it could be looked over
sometimes but she is a genius in it and
I'm like you know what that makes total
sense of course you would be right and I
think it would be interesting to bring
you on here tell your story how you got
to where you are today and uh yeah yeah
everyone that I've talked to by the way
is like oh you had Alex on just wait
until they have Layla on yeah just wait
like
but not one person has said anything
less than like she's a genius you have
to talk to her you have to have her on
the podcast so here we are okay no
pressure no pressure at all but uh yeah
so thank you so much for coming uh give
us a little bit of your back story yeah
and what led up to everything that has
inspired so far yes if we rewind back
um just to give context I think
sometimes it's you start a little bit
sooner so I'll go back to when I was in
high school so high school
um started getting into fitness I was
always overweight as a kid and so I kind
of pursued figuring out you know food
working out all that stuff and that
caught my interest when I was like 13.
and so I actually didn't stick with
really any sports I started going to the
gym and like lifting by myself and so
that was really the only form of like
physical fitness that I did
um and then when I was around I want to
say like I learned enough that then when
I was at the age of like 18 19 I end up
losing like 85 pounds and so first I use
that as context because I think going
through like a fitness transformation
losing a ton of weight like that and
like changing your identity is really
similar to becoming you know someone
who's successful in business right it's
like becoming successful in one area of
your life kind of translates over to the
other and so then I went to college for
exercise science thinking that I would
attain some kind of skill set that would
allow me to like one day have a business
which was very wrong
um and so I went to school and I think
like two years in I realized like this
is not going to do anything for me and
so when I went to college and I realized
that it was basically useless and there
was nothing for me to learn um I started
you know investing myself so I started
listening like Tony Robbins Jim Rohn
um and I started really paying attention
like what do I want to do when I get out
of here because I kind of was just
finishing it for the sake of finishing
it like my dad was a professor
um and so I got like I literally paid
like 25 tuition because he worked there
so it was like you know I just honestly
I didn't take it seriously I wasn't like
a bad student but I also wasn't like
super good I just like thought it was
useless and I was like I can learn more
on my own and from other people that I'm
studying right now and so I did a lot
more of that and then I knew that I
wanted to compete in Fitness and move
out to California and so I graduated
college and I was like okay I understand
everything about the human body very
useless like I got that by now it's like
I'd read enough books that I was like
this isn't really going to help me a ton
because that can only take me so far I
need to learn how to like build a
business and market and sell so I lived
in Michigan at that point in time and I
was like
pretty much everyone there was like from
at least the town that I was in it's
like okay you're either gonna like you
know maybe take over the small business
of your parent you know work at striker
or like work at one of the big
automobile places in Detroit like it
wasn't a lot of opportunity
um at least nothing that I wanted to do
or apply myself I didn't see myself in
big corporate so I packed up my Prius at
the time nice and uh I was two days
after I graduated college I just drove
out to California uh and got some
disgusting you know apartment that was
like as cheap as I could find that I
pulled up and I was like oh this is in
the ghetto great this is good for like a
single you know like 21 year old girl
um and I moved there and then I was like
okay I need to get a job within walking
distance because I don't want to pay for
gas too much because like I have like
eight thousand dollars at this point
which when rent is like 1500 a month
you're like okay this isn't gonna last
too long with like food and all the
other things
um so I went and I applied at every gym
nearby and I was like I'll just start
working at a gym at first because like I
know I could get a job at a gym
um and then I'll learn sales I'll learn
sales for the gym and then eventually
I'll learn more about business this and
have my own business I didn't know what
kind of business but I just knew I
wanted some kind of business so I ended
up getting a job at all the places I
applied and so I tried like a couple of
them out for a couple weeks
um and I ended up staying with 24 Hour
Fitness
why are you looking at me like that I'm
just curious why 24 Hour Fitness out of
all of the the other locations well I
won't say the name of some of them but
like one of them I went to and you know
within like the first few days I was
like oh you know they were basically
like hey you need to pull down your
shirt a little bit hike up those shorts
and you're gonna get those Indian men
over there and I was like that's not how
I not a flow man okay so like I get that
that's like extremely
um advantageous in the fitness industry
like a lot of women are totally fine
with doing that and like I don't judge
them for doing that that's just like not
me I just never want to do that
um that's not how I want to like I want
to prove that I'm good at business not
that I can use my body to get business
um so I actually end up sticking with 24
because I really like the manager there
he was really encouraging and he was
like dude I can train you so much and
like I can you know teach you my skill
set and he was like he had basically
taken that gym and made it like the top
24-Hour Fitness for personal training so
I was like okay I'm gonna learn how to
sell here and so I ended up going there
and
um within the first you know basically
there's like 20 other people that they
hired around the same time and I
remember they told me like you need to
go out and get referrals you need to get
like I don't know it was like 15 or 20
referrals I didn't even know if that was
a lot or not at that point in time but
basically in order to do that um you
have to go up to everyone in the gym and
just ask for someone's like name and
phone number and I had no idea at the
time that it was even hard to do that or
like a thing and so I think it's really
interesting because a lot of people say
like oh I'm bad at sales I'm like but if
you don't know you're selling which I
didn't know I was like selling or
getting leads at that point in time it
wasn't even that hard and so I ended up
being the person that liked it the most
and so whatever I got the job it
referrals to what uh referrals for like
from members of the gym for people that
would be interested in joining the gym
what what was your Technique in doing
that was it just walking up like hey man
how's it going
uh he he got a friend do you have
friends yeah you have any friends well
uh
how do you yeah how do you do it like
what made you stand out when you were
doing that I honestly just didn't think
it was weird okay I just moved there I
was like I have nothing to lose these
people don't know me I have no
reputation here like what am I gonna do
fail I mean and that's there were two
girls that were like crying outside the
building I was like why are you crying
they're like I don't want to go talk to
strangers and I was like oh Jesus like I
just don't want to be that person so I
was like I'm just gonna go up and I'm
just gonna be like hey my name is Layla
I'm new here I'm curious if you have any
friends that are interested in joining
the gym that's it like just nice and not
weird you know I think a lot of people
get like really weird because they're
nervous and then it makes it worse yeah
um so anyways I end up working there for
uh I don't know maybe like 18 months
um and then I realized you know it was
basically like as soon as you sell
enough people that you're full which
became my roster like my roster was full
um then they just have you you know
selling for other people and I was like
this is a waste of my time like it's
basically like come in as early as
possible before you're training you know
eight sessions a day sell for other
people build build up their rosters and
I was like I don't want to do that did
you get paid to beef up other people's
rosters I mean yeah you do get paid for
it but you don't get paid ongoing so
it's not very appealing to me sure and I
also didn't think a lot of attorneys
were that good okay you know yeah
um it didn't feel ethical
um and so I was like okay one thing that
I learned from uh the book Rich Dad Poor
Dad I read that like in the back room of
the training I remember it said like
work to learn not to make money when
you're young and so I was like okay I
have learned enough here I get it I get
how this works I don't want to move up
the corporate ladder they like tried to
get me to do all that and I was like
that sounds horrible and so I was like
okay I heard about this guy who had this
really great gym and people like he's
like a fantastic leader and he really
knows how to run a business and like he
has a ton of clients and I was like oh I
want to go learn from that guy and so I
ended up reaching out to him uh I want
to say like 18 months into working at
24. and then you know didn't interview
did a couple and it was obvious we got
along really well and so I went and
worked at his gym and at the same time I
started building up like a roster of
online clients because my uh former
coach for because I competed in bikini
competitions she was like you should do
this too I'll feed you a few clients and
then you bring your own and so I was
like okay so then I started kind of
doing both like learning from her in
terms of like online and how that works
and how you like get clients online
um and then learning from him in terms
of like how do you run a business which
that's what I really got to see when I
moved there
and what it allowed me to see was that
really interestingly enough is that the
same effort it takes to build a small
business it's the same effort to take a
big business and so looking at like 24
hour and looking at the small business I
was like it's almost harder to have
small business even because there's less
opportunity for people so like less
people want to work there because it's a
smaller business so they they have less
opportunity or less Runway to like build
something for themselves in there you
know what I mean so you see a lot of
turn in small businesses which makes
sense because they're small so like the
vision has to be small as well so if
people have a big vision for themselves
they don't want to work a small business
which is interesting
um so anyways I worked there
um and then about not long into it like
I want to say seven months um I was on
Bumble and I basically at this point I
was like man I've been single for a
little while I've been dating when I was
in Michigan when I went to California I
was like I just want to build up my
career like I want to be successful and
that was all I really cared about so I
didn't really care about dating and I
didn't really like the guys in the area
either because they just want some girl
that would like shut up and sit and look
pretty and that's not really me so I got
on Bumble and I remember my sales
manager was like listen he's like this
is just like sales he's like it's a
numbers game and I was like that's
completely true and so I committed to
basically like every day when I had
lunch I was like I'll sit and I'll just
swipe for 30 minutes just like that's it
it's just like swiping and deciding
and so I did that and I went on gosh I
think I I did this for like I don't even
know how long until I finally met Alex I
think it was like maybe 13 or 14 months
how many episodes was that in 13 14
months a lot I mean at least one a week
so that's a lot there's a lot wow how
many of this resulted in a second date
not many really okay maybe like three
okay yeah there was like one guy you
know I went on like maybe like eight or
nine dates with and like you know just
that kind of stuff but okay yeah not too
much what did you learn going on all of
these dates people are weird no I'm
kidding people uh
I mean I think what it reinforced for me
is just that it is a number team like a
lot of people like I just you know you
hear women all the time they're like I
just can't find a man I'm like
how hard have you tried like did you
swipe for 14 months that's probably not
yeah but you know what before we go into
that we gotta thank our sponsor ftxus
they're one of the largest US regulated
cryptocurrency exchanges in the world
with millions of users who buy sell
track and trade both crypto and nfts all
in one place with fees that are up to 85
lower than the top competitors now
unless if you guys have been living
under a rock you've probably noticed a
recent dip in crypto and maybe you're
eager to buy and if that's the case we
strongly recommend you guys use the same
app that we use to trade crypto on a
daily basis that's FTX and we've left a
link Down Below in description what's
also really nice is that they allow
automatic recurring buys that allow you
to dollar cost average to the markets on
a regular basis since Market timing is
pretty much impossible this allows you
very simply mind you to buy in all you
got to do by the way is specify what you
want to buy how much you want to buy how
often you want to buy it swipe right and
you're done and you get free crypto on
every single trade you make over ten
dollars so definitely check them out
with that link Down Below in the
description yep and now with that said
let's get back to the podcast again the
link is down below in the description I
think also what I learned is like most
people are not picky in terms of what
they look for in a significant other
because most guys were like well we're
gonna go on another date and I was like
no
and they were like what I'm like oh you
don't want what I want like this is not
a this is clearly not a match but they
were like totally okay and I was like
that's so odd do you know what you're
looking for like have you thought about
what you want in this person and it's
like I would ask them I think have you
thought about what you want in like a
girlfriend and they're like I mean you
good look good you talk I'm like good
and you talk yeah I was like okay and so
I think I was just looking for something
a little more specific
which like I always knew I was like I
want someone that's equally as powerful
like I don't want to be in every
relationship before I met Alex I was
always like the dominant one in the
relationship and I realized I was like I
don't really want that I want someone
who's almost more dominant than me or at
least could be equally powerful and I'm
like that is something cool and I think
when that was probably also when like
power couple started trending on
Instagram and stuff and Twitter
um and so that was what I was really
looking for and so at this point you
know basically what happened was I
swiped uh on Alex and
he messaged me or no I messaged him
because it was Bumble and so the girl
smashes the guy first and then you know
it was basically like he's like this is
stupid being on this platform let's talk
on the phone I was like amazing I don't
want to talk on this platform either
it's such a waste of time and so he
called me and we talked for like 20
minutes and he was like I consider this
to be like our first date and I was like
amazing this is so efficient so
basically we got like all the questions
very efficient did you have a checklist
what did he say to you I feel like he
must have had like uh consist of like
what did you guys talk about yeah um I
think it was mostly like what are your
qualifications so where did you how many
hours a day do you work yeah I think
what's your sales to you know close
ratio yeah right uh you know it was like
do you want kids do you want to get
married what do you see for your life
like all the basic questions that that
would be reasons that people would break
up later that they don't talk about in
the beginning we just talked about that
on the first phone call and so you know
some of it we weren't completely aligned
on at that point in time but we found
like found each other enough interesting
that I think we were like yeah let's go
on a date so then it was just like let's
go meet for Froyo tomorrow you kind of
went with the flow and Alex kind of
initiated that phone call thing I would
imagine being a guy on a dating app
that's not a very effective way to to
find a significant other is just
immediately ask for a phone call and ask
questions like aspirations in life I
don't know I mean I think it might be I
think so I don't know you are weeding
out all the people I guess that like you
wouldn't want to yeah also like I mean
think about like
I don't know I think also like how
attractive someone is is gonna have
something to do with it too because like
a lot of women will put up with [ __ ] and
a lot of guys will put up with
somebody's good looking that's a good
point okay a dating app would do really
well if they had a questionnaire that
you would fill out first that would
filter out stuff like that like do you
want to get married do you want to have
kids
they do yeah
so yeah I guess so but look at like a
like a Tinder no no where like you would
have to use as eHarmony or match.com no
I don't think so but I actually tried
signing up and I was like but like for a
Tinder if you just 10 questions right
like what are your political views would
you date someone with differing
Viewpoint like stuff like that right
yeah it would be useful yeah you know
what I think would be really really cool
um I'm not single I'm married now but
um I'm never the type of person that
would go to bars or clubs and
everybody's meeting people there yeah
and I also don't like like online places
but I think it'd be cool if you went to
a place and like uh I don't it could be
like fun too so uh it's like a
restaurant but maybe you're seated with
other people and you could do like
single matching or you could do like
group matching and meet new friends or
something I don't know something like
that I think would be cool for their
friend match uh Kinda Yeah but in person
yeah that makes sense I would probably
attend that huh it could also be used
for like meeting potential dates too
because you could do like a just like a
two-seater table you know you could be
single and then have another single
person or you can go with a group of
friends and meet you know more friends
and get to know about them over dinner
because I don't go to clubs and stuff so
it sounds lovely actually I like doing
the online stuff it is efficient yeah
you just scope people out ahead of time
yeah you know what I mean yeah that's
fair so tell us more about this call so
after the college like we already did
the first date the second date
yes then we went for Froyo the next day
which I tried to get out of and he was
like no why try to get out of it I was I
said I was sick or something I think I
was hungover really okay there's nothing
to do with that so you were hungover you
said you were literally never drank and
it was like a friend's birthday and it
was the first time like 18 months I
drank him so I was like I'm sick he's
like you sound fine let's go I was like
okay I just liked how assertive he was I
was like he said you sound fine let's go
yeah that sounds like him just like him
with stairs like it baffles me every
time but could you get away with that
Jack no you sound fine let's go
I'm a woman who like I've been looking
for a man who can actually like be more
assertive with me everyone I've dated
has been passive I've always over
dominated those people so like to have
somebody who's finally like no we're
gonna go do this I'm like
I like that that's nice okay I'm saying
yeah so he ended up not forcing you but
like really forcing me yeah so selling
you into this this froy pitch yeah yeah
yeah so then we went to Frodo the next
day and um we didn't talk about like
relationships at all we actually just
talked about business all the time so we
like walked for four hours we had the
Froyo I don't even think he liked me in
the very beginning actually actually I
know he didn't because he walked up and
I have a giant back tattoo and he saw my
back tattoo and when he said hi he was
like Hey I was like no smile I was like
this is so odd right and I was like
maybe if he's having a bad day I don't
know and then we went inside and he ate
and then afterwards I find out too that
you know when his blood sugar's low he's
very cranky so I think after he ate it
it helped but then he told me he's like
why do you have a giant back tattoo and
I was like I don't know I was 18. yeah
it's not like getting it
um what was his response to that started
off I think all right okay he's like
whatever I'm here right but she's like
you could get that removed what are your
plans tomorrow
you'll get that removed yeah yeah I met
his dad the first time as Dad he came
from behind he sees me he goes we can
get this removed it doesn't even say hi
[Laughter]
have you gotten it removed no dude I
went through like one session and the
guy was like he was like well we could
do it now uh but you won't be numb but
like if you come back you know then we
can numb it's gonna be a few weeks out
because I'm booked I was like how bad is
it he was like it's not that bad you
know
and I was like okay it's only my whole
back like let's just try yeah so he did
like a little thing and I was like wow
that's terrible then I was like just do
it so I sat there and like no it was the
worst pain I've ever had wow I always
thought that they should have just one
massive laser for something like that
yes
and it's just like you know and it just
does the entire session right yeah they
bite on a towel knock me out like this
is actually pretty aggressive it feels
like bacon grease is just popping on
your back really that's what it feels
like yeah identical
I've always been so curious in what it's
like I've heard it's very painful oh I
would not I was like I must yeah numb
included cream is like I get those
videos recommended to me on Tick Tock
now yeah because I started watching them
get so addicting like they just go
through the like I want to just watch it
done
he almost told the guy to stop because
he was there and I was just like
convulsing because it like the way that
it hits your nerves and so you just like
you like flop is this thing like
straight up shoulders to like you know
yeah yeah so wow okay super tacky so I
so Alex when he was on here I think he
mentioned that pretty early on in the
first couple dates I think I think he
might have said like the second date
um he said that he had to like do
something for for like a business he was
running or something and uh that you
just like kind of went along with it so
how did that come up what did you think
going on you know one of the first dates
with this person and just being like
told like hey I'm working on this
business yeah how did that make you feel
and did you feel intimidated or did you
did you like that he took charge
um intimidated no I I actually was like
he asked me to pick up all the cash from
his that's what it was yeah oh yeah yeah
yeah and I'm more like call him and I
was like bro I was like you don't even
know me I was like why are you ask me to
pick up the cash I was like I'm I'm
happy because he was out of town he was
like I just dropped by the bank by this
day do you think you could help me out
and I was like sure but like I that's a
lot of money like you try you don't even
know me and he was like I know he won't
steal and I was like
interesting and I picked the money I was
like a lot of money it was like if I
were not a good person I was like I
don't how does he even know so I
mentioned to Alex I kind of thought you
know that was him being like yeah pick
up my cash from the gym
100 Grand here this guy's really killing
it you know you take it to the bank do
you think what was it just you needed a
hand with this I mean I think that he
was trying to figure out if he wanted he
was like because you know basically on
the first date he's like we should work
together like I want to start this new
business you seem like you can sell and
you understand business and you like all
this he's like you should do it with me
and I was like we just met like I just
feel like I I was like this a lot like
I'm doing these other things I'm not
sure
um and so I think he like kept slowly
trying to just like get me to like start
working and doing stuff with him so I
feel like it was a little bit of that
and just like necessity like I don't
think like we both didn't have like a
ton of friends at that point in time so
it was like when we gone three dates and
as well did you worry that maybe there's
something illegal going on like he's
having you go and pick up cash from
different locations and like bring it
somewhere did that that never crossed
your mind no they were gyms I like went
in there's like
[Music]
but first Alex and I want to thank
today's sponsor MooMoo Mumu helps you
monitor Market movements perform deep
technical analysis screen for stocks
that you like and it gives you a
community where Traders can exchange
ideas another great feature is you also
get access to global
globe in the U.S stock market all from
the same app and that's actually really
cool for me because there are some
stocks on the Hong Kong market that I
would love to buy and best of all when
you deposit just one hundred dollars
MooMoo will give you up to seven free
stocks each stock is worth at least
eight dollars all the way up to 2500 so
it's literally free money they also have
a 24 7 real-time financial news page so
you can keep up to date with all that
Finance news you might need for your
trades from places like Bloomberg Dow
Jones Reuters CNBC and some other
credible news sources all in one place
MooMoo even has a 24 7 online customer
service line where you can live chat
with their team if you ever need
anything so get up to 10 free stocks
from MooMoo using the link Down Below in
the description again guys the link is
down below in the description to get up
to 10 free stocks thank you so much
MooMoo and back to the podcast so that
was like the second date ever basically
he already hired you to to go pick up
some cash for him and then how did this
evolve into what it is today and now you
guys are are building these crazy huge
businesses yeah I mean I think you know
basically we started a gym launch and
after Alex got rid of all his other
businesses because he had like a
bajillion um and that was very like it
took a ton of attention from him and so
I actually end up you know fast forward
I end up six weeks into US knowing each
other uh quitting the gyms I was at uh
stopping anything with online personal
training and I just went all in on gym
launch
um and then I think it took him
probably close to like a year to shed
everything that he was doing
um but he did because it was also like
every time that he like was like I don't
know if on grids I was like did I quit
my job and like I gave all my clients to
do this because of this idea and so I
think it was it was really cool once he
finally got those things off his plate
and then we realized that we have really
great complementary skill sets and I
think that evolved over time because in
the beginning it was like I we both
could kind of do the same thing so we
just split stuff up and then as Jim
launch ended up taking off which it was
just a concept for 18 months you know it
was basically just like eating [ __ ] and
then
18 months in and we changed the model
and then it just took off you know we
stopped flying people out to the gyms
and instead we started we turned it into
basically uh like an education business
or a licensing model where we licensed
the IP to them and then we coached them
through the program and that was when we
said okay we're not going to be able to
do the same thing and split it anymore
we're going to kind of split roles
because we understand that's what a
business needs in order to function and
so that's when basically you know we
wrote everything on a whiteboard that
happens with the business and it was
like Marketing sales Finance HR Ops you
know customer success I Tech all that
and then uh one of our friends just
circled marketing and like this is Alex
and then all the rest is Layla and they
were like that's how you split it and I
was like
okay and and that was what kind of
stemmed how we worked together and then
like me going into learning the other
parts of a business because I understood
marketing and sales fairly well at that
point not as well as him because he had
his six gems right so he'd had to Market
and sell for those but I understood it
better than most people
um but I didn't understand literally
anything else and so that's when I just
went into learning and like investing in
you know reading books and studying like
how do you run the rest of a business
how do you grow and scale a business
um and that became kind of my hat and
then his hat you know continued and
always went further into marketing and
it's just worked incredibly well and
like we actually really enjoy doing it
together and so we just haven't stopped
at what point did you guys start like
dating though because it seems like yeah
in the beginning it was like a business
venture I mean it's kind of weird
honestly because
foreign
like we were dating during the whole
first year but like more working
together listen this is the thing me and
Alex both our Ambitions are always going
to be what's most important to both of
us and so I think until we realized that
we were both useful in terms of helping
each other achieve their Ambitions it's
kind of like our Ambitions are always
going to be first but once you realize
that that person is going to actually
help you achieve your Ambitions putting
that person first and partnering with
them and putting the partnership first
becomes more of a priority does that
make sense yeah and how long would you
say it took for that to that to occur
where you put each other before the
ambition
maybe two and a half years wow two and a
half
years
it's not like a normal relationship that
I'm like totally aware of but it works
yeah so how did you then scale this
business and what what was your role
exactly yeah uh so we had the titles of
co-ceos and so how we divided it was
really Alex is top of funnel so he's
gonna make it rain right that's always
what Alex is going to do
um in gym launch specifically Alex also
was like the face of the product for the
beginning so until we brought in like
coaches and had them basically redo all
the product he was the face of the
product so he was like in all the videos
so Alex was in all the videos he was
running the marketing and I did the rest
of it and so that's how we've always
split it because he's definitely
somebody who like he needs to focus on
one thing so it's like I always in any
business that we start I'm like I'm
gonna try and get Alex like in a corner
focusing on one thing because that's
what he likes doing like he likes
writing his books he likes promoting he
likes making content like he likes doing
that stuff I like the rest of it I like
the people stuff I like building teams I
like hiring leaders I like doing all
those things and so that's how we've run
all the businesses in terms of gym
launch it was was a little bit in the
beginning of us overlapping and then
learning that we had to let go of things
in order to be more effective just as a
business you know it's like we had to
Define our own roles have our own job
descriptions you know basically like if
you look at if we weren't in a
relationship how would we run the
business that's just what we did because
we're like that's going to make the
business successful as if we're partners
that we clearly Define our roles and
then we give each other autonomy to make
decisions in those areas does that make
sense yeah how often do you guys get in
disagreements and if you are at a
stalemate who makes that decision
we actually were given a really great
piece of advice early on which was if
you don't agree don't move forward and
so people ask us that all the time
especially if they're interested in
working for us they're like how do you
guys as co-founders and as married a
married couple like make decisions more
like there's an honestly not one like
final decision maker we just wait until
we agree on something like we continue
to work the idea or the problem until we
both like it and then we move forward
and that means like I can think of the
biggest time that we had a disagreement
was with Alan launching the software
company
um which I think I've talked about this
before but basically like I just when we
had a minimum viable product I looked at
everything that had to happen in order
to make it a scalable business and I was
like I don't think it's worth it I don't
I think we're going to incur like
Millions like four million dollars into
this thing I was like it's gonna cost
way more and I don't think that we're
gonna see the return we want and the
market moves so fast and Tech and Tech
is not our strong suit that I didn't
believe it was like a great you know
Venture and he was like I think it is
and because he's always more optimistic
I'm usually more pessimistic and so we
like locked ourselves in a room for like
three days
and then finally I was like screw it
like okay the the deal was that we would
launch it and we would try and build it
and scale it but if it didn't become
profitable within four months we would
shut it down and so like it's kind of
funny because literally like at month
two I was like dude
it's not looking good
and he was like he just like dove in and
it became extremely profitable
um and so we ended up growing it to an
extent and then selling it but we sold
it because again it just wasn't our
strong suit so we always look back we're
like who's right who was wrong it's like
neither or right but it did make money
so it made a profit oh yeah yeah it
ended up doing that it was just very uh
painful is probably the right word
because we don't have we're not like
technical experts you know like I'm
great at running a business and the
operation side of things and he's great
at marketing and there was no product
person yeah and so if we had started
with a product person I think it would
have done like I think it would have
crushed
um but we just we didn't do that we
didn't know yeah and what about the
decision to sell everything scale back
how involved were you in that process
what were your thoughts on that super
involved
um
I actually you know I think he probably
wanted to like sell the house before me
um I think part of it was like wanting
to feel like like I had for a long time
or at least for like a few years of our
marriage because it's only been like six
years
uh you know I had this image of like I
want to be like the perfect CEO the
perfect wife the perfect you know
employer the perfect boss like all these
things and part of being like the
perfect wife and the perfect like
I don't know just human that I was
envisioning was like having this huge
house that was like very impressive that
people could walk into and so I think
finally what was like the Tipping Point
for me was realizing how much of my
attention was going to that house and I
think one of my friends I was talking to
her one day about it and she's like do
you know how much more valuable your
attention is on the business and I was
like I agree with you and so I think at
that point then it just became a
nuisance to me because I was like I'm so
sick of taking care of this like I'm not
a traditional wife and I think it was
like I resisted that for a long time
because I'm around all these other wives
who like they don't run businesses they
don't they're like they run a business
with their husband but like they don't
run the business with their husband
they're actually like doing something
else and like they have lots of free
time to take care of the house which is
great that's just not me and I think for
a long time I didn't accept that about
myself once I accepted it I was like
screw this I was like I'm not cooking
dinner anymore I don't want this house I
don't want this car because I want to
take care of this
and so now I realize there are other
ways to do that but I in hindsight I'm
glad that we did it because it was like
a fresh start it's also because like you
know we knew that we're gonna sell the
businesses and I was like I want a fresh
start like I feel like I'm like gym
launched Layla in this house and
acquisition.com Layla doesn't live in
this house she doesn't do this [ __ ] she
doesn't cook this dinner like this she
doesn't do any of this and so it's much
easier to change your life if you change
your environment at least we both tend
to think that and so you know moving
selling the house getting rid of all
cars and everything like just doing a
fresh start I think was like really good
for turning the page to the next chapter
yeah and now you're living in uh middle
of Las Vegas strip what is that like it
was awful in a hotel yeah I didn't like
it at all but Alex had always wanted to
try Las Vegas and I was like listen I'm
flexible and like I just always am one
of those people I'm like I'm not gonna
not try something once so we got like a
lease and I was like what is it I can do
anything for a year
um and so we moved there at first I
didn't like it because it was very loud
and very like busy
um and now it's odd it's like I actually
really like it really yeah what do you
like the most about it everybody always
comes to Las Vegas and everybody always
stays on the Strip so the amount of like
networking amount of people that we can
see and things that we can do the amount
of activities that there are that you
can do on the strip I actually really
like that and so it's like if people
come in you know you you know where to
take them you know what to do there's
lots that you can do you don't have to
like entertain people in your home and I
love being able to walk to everything
versus you know we were kind of isolated
in the suburbs before when we were in
Austin which I was not a big fan of I
would find it so weird just to like take
an escalator or take an elevator down
and like there's thousands of people
that are just a few stories below you it
is a little weird it's just an odd time
mindset yeah yeah people think the strip
they think of like you know the Mirage
and like we live in the other side was a
little nicer a little more quiet so it's
like our like very intermediate
surrounding area is more of the nicer
side of the strip which I don't talk
about what it is but yeah that's fair I
want to talk a little bit more about
business operations because you say
that's kind of what you do with now it's
acquisition.com previously was gym
launch yeah what do you think you're
uniquely good at within business
operations and how did you get good at
those things you said hiring was one of
them you think that you're yeah I think
I think it's a couple I think
probably good at picking people I think
I'm fairly probably more competent than
most people at hiring for sure
um and then also managing people like I
really think that's I think it's just
like it's building the team right and I
think that doing that and aligning it
with the strategy of the business is
something I feel really good at doing
like I can I know where the business
projections are for like three to five
years from now and I'm like oh I know
what the team's gonna look like I can
map it out on a piece of paper and do
that I would say it's probably like my
bigger Advantage
um I'd be interested in what my team
would say actually I'm like what would
they say what do you look for in a
person like is there a quality yeah and
how do you build out the team and the
culture of the team yeah it starts with
you which is like the weird okay what I
hate is that there's like an art and a
science to this right the culture is the
art side and I think that a lot of
people there is a obviously science
there's like you can do these things but
if the heart isn't there and the
intention isn't there it's not going to
happen and so I think a lot of times
it's very misconstrued because people
see like a Jeff Bezos or an Elon Musk
and they're like oh the culture and all
these things but he's he's honestly an
outlier most people that have very big
businesses are just people of like Elite
character
because people want to people that have
Elite Talent want to work for people
with the elite character right so if you
think about it like I think about my job
I don't need to be the smartest person
in the room but I need to be of sound
enough mind and competent enough that
the smartest person in the room wants to
work for me
and that I've created a big enough
Vision that their vision for however
smart they are can fit within mine so I
look at that as my job I'm like that's
what I do
um
and I think that when you think about
building a culture oftentimes it's just
it continues the culture is like you
start the top and it just continues to
dilute all the way down and the culture
is really just the mission and the
vision and the values of the co-founder
or of the founder or the person that's
you know whatever head haunch of the
business whatever you want to call them
right and so it just continues to drip
down and so the more potent you can be
in terms of how you exemplify those
values and that mission the more that
you can repeat it over and over again
the stronger a culture you're going to
have because it's going to the next
level is going to be like a little
diluted and then like a little more
diluted and then like a little more so
the bigger the organization that's why
you see that people lose the mission and
the values it's unless you make it an
immense effort and it starts with the
person at the top unfortunately it's
like nobody's going to exemplify those
values more than the person at the top
it's like you think about it I've seen
it so many times it's just nobody will
work for you
that has better values than you they
will go find somebody else who has
better values and within operations of a
business if you see that dichotomy of
like culture and talent would you be
able to say one is more important than
the other
it's a good question
culture you did I think that without
culture Talent fails
interesting so it becomes a very cold
environment so you think culture is
probably more important than Talent yeah
I'm just wondering it's like if if
you're building a business or if I'm
trying to create a team how can I
radiate that that positive culture that
you're saying or like constantly be
instilling the values of the company
into the employees of the company is it
like actual like board meetings like
more specifically what exactly is it
yeah like tactically if you're looking
at it like it really is down to the
tactics which is like first you start
with you know quarterly meetings like
this sounds so lame but like that's
really hey dude it's like you have an
annual meeting you've got quarterly
meetings and each of those you're
reiterating the mission the vision the
values over and over again and you're
showing how all of the goals of the
business tie into those values tie into
that mission and so those values in that
mission are actually decision making
filters to decide are these the
priorities that we need to follow as a
company do they align with the values
and do they relate to the mission if the
mission is we want to help a thousand
women lose weight and someone says well
I want to start a men's weight loss
program it's like but it's helped women
lose weight not men so that means that
decision's out
and so a lot of people just think
they're like these Fufu things I'm like
no these are the principles that we use
to make decisions for the company and so
they should always be prominent because
that's what so I'll give you an example
right with acquisition.com it's sincere
Candor unimpeachable character and then
competitive greatness and so every time
we're picking a CEO portfolio company we
run them through that filter we have a
scorecard and it literally has this as a
filter it's like do they fit those
values would they be something that
we're proud to associate with do they
have sincere Candor are they being
transparent with us and then do they
want more than money are they actually
competitively great and the same goes
for hiring is that I have a little
scorecards like do they fit the values
and that's always the first question
it's like it doesn't matter how skilled
they are if they don't fit the values
they just can't work here
and so I think it's it's that and then
when I talk about those quarterly
meetings those get broken down into you
know on a monthly basis I think that
most companies should be running what I
call is like a vision meeting which is
again reiterating the vision it's just
repetition of the vision to the entire
company and then talking about the
vision breaking it down to the actual
Mission and then the values and then
giving examples of decisions that were
made that month that relate to that it's
like hey guys we decided not to do this
because of this value and then calling
people out it's like Sally actually did
this this month which relates to our
value number two you know Harry didn't
do this because he realized it didn't
relate to our value or it didn't tie
into our mission does that make sense
that makes sense it's like you're just
always using those as like The Guiding
Light and tying every decision back to
them of why we do or do not do something
in a company
that's really interesting you have like
your overarching goal or Mission and
every action that is taken within the
business should always be serving that
main goal absolutely
I think we could do that a little bit
better probably do that because you said
like quarterly meetings within us it's
like we go out we do dinners on occasion
like I'm seeing Graham fairly often I'm
seeing Alex like fairly often yeah we
never like allocate or Reserve time
specifically to just discuss the
intricacies of the business I feel like
that's what we always talk about though
it's what we talk about but I feel like
it's it's more conversational it is like
an actual yo we're doing a business yeah
you know what I mean yeah what is the
mission
foreign
so glad you asked this question isn't it
Jack yeah that it's a great question
Alex uh I don't know to be honest I mean
the mission has always been continue
having fun and growing I mean I always
put just enjoyment over anything okay so
just uh I I mean obviously it would be
cool to hit a million subscribers but I
think you have to enjoy it and for me
it's it's really enjoyment first and as
long as they see growth month over month
as long as we're you know on an upward
trajectory we're continued continuing to
do well and just growing I'm happy with
it I think it's growth for me I would
say like the overall mission of the iced
coffee hour getting on as many platforms
as possible getting as many views having
on the best quality guests that we can
providing the most like amount of
entertainment and educational value for
the viewers just growth why is growth
important because I think that happiness
is derived from growth yeah and
productivity I think I like I like
watching the progress to me it's a bit
like a challenge to see month over month
or even like you know six months over
six months are we doing better if not
why and trying to figure that out it's
like a piece of a puzzle that you could
you could figure out and grow and but I
think at the end of the day for me it's
just like do you have fun doing it is it
something that I look forward to and if
it's a yes then I continue doing it I
think that's a value like the fun piece
is totally a value like we have a
company and their values pig in the mud
fun right but they have like a huge
Vision it's just like hey if we're not
having fun like we want to make sure we
have fun while we get there values are
basically constraints of how you get to
the vision so it's like we can get to a
billion dollar company or make this you
know somehow turn it into a billion
dollar company as long as we're having
fun because that's a constraint we're
putting on ourselves like Hey we're
gonna get there but we have fun along
the way if we're not having fun that's
not along with the mission does that
make sense yeah yeah good question
yeah that makes a lot of sense if you
actually like wrote it down and you were
like this is our mission and like
because here's the thing is at some
point yeah you're gonna hit a million
subscribers you're gonna hit these
numbers you're talking about and then
what
then you just bump it up yeah that's
that's a goal or a kpi a mission is
something above that it's like why even
set the goal or kpi sure what's the
greater Vision Beyond it you know what I
mean like it's usually very amorphous
and that's totally fine but it's just
like you can attract better people
better talent and then like align with
that I feel like you guys already have
everything that they're just not written
down or structured you know yeah great
suggestion yeah I like that yeah honing
it in yeah it gives people so much
Clarity because so many opportunities
come in to every business owner they
come their way and people always like
how do you say no to Opportunities I'm
like I just run into the decision filter
it's like does it align with the mission
or the values if it does then maybe it
makes sense for us to pursue if it
doesn't then we say no to it even if
it's a great opportunity it's not our
opportunity yeah I will say one thing
that's kind of interesting is if we
record a podcast and I think that
podcast did like or I think that it was
extremely entertaining or extremely
educational and it doesn't perform that
well it still makes me feel better than
an episode where I feel like we didn't
do that much but it still gets a lot of
views I'll say that so maybe it is just
providing as much value
as possible I get that because I make
videos that like nobody watches but I'm
like so good it's very valuable so yeah
yeah you were telling us though that you
don't even watch YouTube you don't watch
Tick Tock you stay off of all of that I
forget what we mentioned oh it was a
mukbang we were talking about doing a
mukbang I don't know I don't even know
what that is I don't watch YouTube I'm
like mukbang you know is there a reason
why you stay away from like Tick Tock or
YouTube it's not uh like a tool that's
helping me get to my goals yeah I guess
you run it through the decision filter
it's not honestly you know I don't have
a if I need to learn something I will
pick like what platform I could probably
find something on I will go learn it but
it's not like I don't like have fun on
social media like for me social media is
like I only think about putting out
content that adds value to other people
and that's the only like purpose I see
social media for I don't see it for like
my own entertainment if that makes sense
that's interesting because I always find
it really interesting when people that
are really successful at social media
don't consume social media because I
feel like you need to consume social
media in order to see
I study like all the time I'm like
always trying to network and talk to
other like podcast producers and stuff
like that and even studying podcasts and
like how they break down their
conversation like I'm always looking at
stuff like that and I would imagine it's
pretty hard to try to scale on social
media if you aren't like allowing
yourself or consuming any of it yeah but
that's my goal I mean like I'm I'm
putting stuff out there because I think
that it's
I want to represent the other side of
our business like me and Alex talked
about when we started access.com which
is it's basically like the two of us
split the role of CEO and so people only
see what he does and they assume oh
that's all I need to be successful and
we talk about it like when we start
access.com I was like I want to put a
presence out there but it's not my
number one priority right now because
I'm growing and scaling our business and
so like my team is my priority right now
and like growing the team and growing
the portfolio companies and I would
sacrifice social media any day to make
sure that I put them as a priority so
it's just like what's my priority it
would be his priority right because like
Alex is more top of funnel than I am
it's like it should for sure be his he's
on the platforms way more than me he
understands marketing to a different
extent than I do
um I listen to what he says I listen to
our team I listen to like Caleb and
Quinn and everyone that we have and I
Look to them I'm like what do you guys
think like what content do you think I
should be making that's I asked them
because I'm like I don't know what's
valuable
so what is your goal over the next 10
years your mission yeah I want to be the
CEO of acquisition.com when it hits a
billion and how are you going to do that
how are you going to get to a billion
um it's a fairly I mean there's a lot of
different ways that we could do it so I
mean we could have
uh I think it's 100 companies doing you
know 30 million a year we could have you
know 50 companies that are each doing uh
40 or 50 million a year I mean like
there's a lot of different ways
math-wise it works out I think right now
what we're doing is we're taking
minority interest in smaller companies
and so it's like more of a volume game
but what I would like to eventually do
is take majority stake in bigger
companies because here's the thing I've
realized is that scaling a smaller
company and scaling a bigger company
it's the same work and like honestly I
can do both and so I feel like but what
I have to do is I have to build the team
that can do both right now I think our
infrastructure supports scaling the
companies that are you know below 100
million but I think we can get the level
of talent to scale companies Beyond 100
million and like take them to you know I
would love to get accompanied to a
billion that would be so sad what sort
of companies do you go after
um we've actually just broadened it so
it was more service-based educational
Etc and at the last quarterly I was like
I feel like this is very limiting
because we can take technology we can
take you know physical Goods it's just
it's more about the business itself a
lot of Technology businesses and
physical Goods businesses have really
crappy margins and really bad economies
of scale and so oftentimes they end up
going under because they just one they
take on like VC money if you're Tech and
then if you're a product business you
have like loans and lines of credit
constantly going in and out and so it's
like there's not much left over at the
end of the day and so to reinvest in
like building you know a talent pool and
stuff without taking on more debt which
is not something I'm comfortable with
asking people to do it's really hard and
our method of growing a company is
basically we want to take it to the
organic Max before we take it to it's
basically like leveraged maximum so
every company has like an organic Max
where it's like if you've seen an
s-curve in a company right it's like the
product is like doing great it's going
up and then all of a sudden like it
starts to go down decline people start
eating away at your market share
competitors come in you start to see
your clients are leaving for other
people and then the goal is to then
basically build a new s-curve and
overlap the two and if you can overlap
the two then you can go from say usually
the first S curve for a lot of
businesses that I'd be talking to it'd
be like 50 million and then they get to
50 million around 45 they start to see a
decline and they can hit 50 with like
you know a ton of grit and then at that
point it's like you need something new
to scale to 100 million and Beyond and
so
um the goal is really to just take them
to the organic Max what it is that a lot
of companies
they don't go to their organic Max they
get to like two three million and then
they're like we're gonna get all this VC
money and we're just gonna throw money
at everything the thing is if you've
seen the inside of some of those
companies it takes someone very
disciplined to not solve problems with
just money and if you solve problems
with just money the company is basically
built on stilts
and how do you help all these businesses
scale where do you find all the time to
do that time yeah well we have a team
okay so yeah we have a team it's not
like it's just me and Alex that's right
it's not at all how big is your team uh
12. it's mostly comprised of Consultants
so people who specialize in like
strategy and certain areas of business
they can help scale those areas does
that make sense it's like you look like
MacKenzie or Bane or like some of those
firms that's what we're going for but
like a new kind of
Consulting PE sure and walk us through
an average day now like what your
schedule looks like how many hours you
work yeah
um usually I wake up at like five I want
to say
um and then I really like to just get to
work for like
I don't know three hours maybe and then
at like eight or nine I go to the gym
uh and usually I'm like walking doing
emails and then I go Lyft
um then I come back and I shower and
then I take calls from usually like uh I
don't like to do them any earlier than
10 if I don't have to because I'd like
to get my work done in the morning
um but like 10 to uh maybe like 5 30 and
then I go on a walk and then usually we
have some sort of like dinner or event
or something in the afternoon
um and then we do that and then we come
home and Alex and I like debrief with
each other and then that's it I have a
question
um so we had Alex on he said he would
consider himself a nihilist would you
consider yourself a nihilist
I don't like identify with that term I
think that I have beliefs that would be
aligned with that but I don't like think
about myself or identify I don't label
myself with any label so that's probably
actually why
but do we share the same beliefs mostly
but I think he's Alex is more
philosophical than I am like I actually
try to get out of my head because I can
overthink and go into that really deep
and I don't like to as much I just
like I don't think most things matter
and you can just assign whatever meaning
you want to like you get to choose
whatever meaning that you have and
assign it to whatever occurs I do
believe that
um I don't think anything has like
inherent meaning
um but I don't think about that all the
time because if you stay stuck in there
it's just like a very like I don't want
to be a you know I tell Alex I'm like I
don't want to be a philosopher yeah I'm
like that's not it's not my God yeah I
want to be a business person so
um makes sense yeah yeah but I I do
think that serves me foreign
earlier and you walked in you saw Bailey
the puppy you got a puppy too
could you tell us the story you said you
just brought brought a puppy home yeah
Alex wasn't a big fan or something no he
loves dogs and that's why he doesn't
want one
um
so there was like a period of time right
before we got married that
Alex and I he basically was like I need
to tie up some loose ends or something
you like want to talk like an ex because
he had been engaged before we met and I
was like talk to an ex I was like okay
and so he's like you know I'm gonna meet
her uh at some place whatever and I'm
gonna like you know close things off
because they just left it like maybe
we'll get back together because they've
been on and off for so long
and I was like pretty sure we're just
breaking up and so when he was gone I
was like okay and I just like went to
get my own apartment and I got a dog and
he came back and he was like I closed
things off I want to get married and I
was like wait what and I was so confused
I was like wait dude come on how long
was he gone for two days two days where
do you go oh he flew and then came back
the next day oh my God but he was
previously engaged to this woman what
was there to close off did you guys have
a discussion like why like why couldn't
I was saying this time right okay you're
gonna close something off you know like
I'm just like this is a weird thing to
just not to say like you know shoot a
text or something like that or like uh
well you know I think
um I don't know much about the situation
because I don't I don't like tend to ask
about people's past I think that it was
his situation he wanted to handle his
way
um and I think he handled it very
maturely which was that person felt like
there was enclosure and so he was like I
feel that she deserves to hear from me
in person and I'm going to tell her why
she needs to move on and she is with
somebody else who I think wanted to get
married with her and she was like do I
do that or we ever do we ever have a
future and I don't know he could
probably tell it better than me my
memory is not like 100 Onyx like I was
just more like
well obviously so Within These two days
you got your own apartment and a dog I
didn't get the own apartment I like went
and viewed them and then I got a dog
because I was like I want a dog so you
thought I was like a dog huh you thought
it was over yeah but he told you he was
just gonna come back right but how many
people when they're like oh I have to go
close things off with my ex you're like
okay you know what I mean like I'm I
just was thinking of myself that you
accepted the fact that it was over you
got a dog and then he comes back all
right let's go you know well I kind of
realized that I just like let my own
mind get the best of me oh I mean how
many that makes sense like think about
like every relationship I'd had prior to
that if somebody had said something like
that like I I did have people who were
Unfaithful and like did things like that
so I was like oh I've seen this before
okay
but this wasn't the case you just
noticed that as soon as you came back
you're like well I already got the dog
so yeah and I think that was like a huge
moment where I gained a lot of trust
with him because I was like he's I mean
Alex is like he's never cheated on
anyone he's always been very faithful
he's always been very forthright about
that he would never do that to somebody
and I always was like wow he's very
aggressive about this fact about himself
when we met and that kind of showcased
it to me because I was like he came back
and he was just like he seemed like much
more clear of head and he's like I feel
like really good about this now and like
I can completely focus on this because
when we met he was like I wasn't really
looking for a relationship I was just
looking for a distraction yeah from this
relationship that I was like exiting
yeah does that make sense how is being
married changed your relationship or has
it no okay has not why I'm curious I'm
engaged yeah well I'm engaged now so I'm
curious if you've seen a shift or
something I think if anything
it just allows you a level of intimacy
that's beyond what you had before
because there's this
whether it's false or not a bigger sense
of certainty and security with the
person because you're like we're married
like it's almost like a like it used to
just be like okay together and then you
could break up now it's like together
and it's like if you even had the
thought to break up you're like wait but
we're married it's almost like a stop
Gap I want to say and so you like you
would have to take things more seriously
and like consider things and try much
harder in order to end the relationship
and I do think that most people actually
don't try very hard to save
relationships so I do think
uh what other marriage advice do you
have
or anything
yeah I'm serious I'm just curious
everything's going great Jack yeah yeah
except when I tell you about this thing
don't complain for a second
um the way I see marriage is like this
if you study I think that marriage is a
team sport and so if you look at the
best teams of all time how do they
structure like what are they built off
of I think it's the same things which is
it's like you have a shared mission
shared values
and then shared lifestyle or interests
basically so it's like shared mission is
that you're both going towards the same
thing in life there's something that
you've decided that you can have your
own ways of getting there and you have
your own paths but you both want to end
up at the same place
right and so you have this goal this
Vision that you can both kind of like
ideate over together
below that is like we have shared values
which is we agree that we abide by these
values to get to that Vision right so
like while we're on our paths there
these are the ways that we're going to
behave in order to achieve the mission
which is like say we want to get rich
we're like oh we want to have a billion
dollars but it's like hey we're also
going to be ethical right so it's like
we're not going to sell cocaine to get a
billion dollars because like we consider
that not to be ethical right and then
the last piece to it is shared lifestyle
or interests which is a lot of people
only have their love for each other in
common they have nothing else in common
besides the fact of their attraction or
their love for one another and so they
don't have activities or things that
they can share and kind of collaborate
over outside of that it's like the only
thing in the relationship is actually
the relationship itself does that make
sense yeah but it's like what if you
looked at them as like would I be best
friends with this person right like do I
have interests and hobbies and things
that I can do with them outside of just
like oh my I love you so much and like
you're amazing and let's have sex I
wonder how many viewers you make
question in their relationship right now
because I've never looked at it that way
like the mission above all else and then
values and then but that makes perfect
sense yes very good sense actually I
always thought that it was values at the
top and then you know like
shared interest yeah I always think it's
commonalities at the top yeah but I feel
like mission that makes sense well it
depends on what kind of life you want to
live too yeah I suppose right yeah yeah
I've seen it work for a lot of people
have long lasting relationships so I
would like to stay I mean like me and
Alex have the same thing which like we
could just be married to each other for
forever we would be super excited about
that which a lot of people don't have
that they're like hey I want to be
married to multiple people and like this
might only last 10 years like I'm super
cool with all that I would just prefer
to be married for a very long time
dislike seems much easier both of us the
vision that we each have for ourselves
is of someone who can be married for 50
or 60 years and why do you want to focus
on building this business so much when
is enough enough or is it just always
about the growth it's yeah it's not
about accumulation of anything it's not
about money it's not about power or
status like none of that it's what else
am I going to do with my time like
I think that and I really get it now
with acquisition.com which is you have
to build a vision compelling enough that
others can fit their Vision inside of it
and that you can fit your next Vision
inside of it I only see you know Layla
as she currently stands able to get this
business to you know 100 something
million I have to become a different
person in order to hit a billion or to
hit 10 billion or 30 or 50 billion and
that is super compelling to me because
I'm like that's a challenge that I would
like to figure out that's something I
would like to and I would like to meet
that person I would like to meet Layla
when she has a 10 billion dollar company
and be like how did you do it what did
you have to go through like what kind of
person do you have to become and what
beliefs did you have to break in order
to get there and so for me it's about
setting a goal so big that I am forced
to change and evolve in a positive way
as a human in order to get there and the
other people within it also have to do
the same because that's what keeps
people excited but that's just because
you find personal enjoyment in that yeah
I like
I like proving to myself
that I'm tough what if you picked up
some random hobby let's say golfing and
you enjoyed golfing way more let's just
say in this like this is a theory right
like spike ball Spike boss or any any
sort of random thing you loved it so
much for the sake of the army was
golfing um but um or ping pong you love
ping pong way more than running your
business everything uh obviously you
loved Alex right
um would you stop doing your business in
order to to do ping pong if you loved it
more than your business
because love is fleeting it's a Feeling
but like logically what makes sense in
order to for me to evolve as a person is
to have Challenge and that is within the
business ping pong would not have that
but then wouldn't that mean you love the
challenge more than you love ping pong
maybe yeah there's always something
that's better in ping pong but there's
always someone that's better because
then I think it for you it's a challenge
but if you're challenged and loved ping
pong assuming all else then I think it
would make sense you would follow ping
pong if I was challenged by ping pong
yes and you like you were loved and
challenged by people but but you made no
money this year yeah so because if if
you're saying it's not about the money
there's got to be a component about it
that is it is somewhat yeah whatever I'm
not following it I don't choose things
because I love them yeah
that makes sense why do you choose
things because they make sense
like logically like I'm like this
business makes the most sense and is
like the most likely vehicle to create
the kind of person I want to create that
I have to become to to run this business
ping pong logically doesn't make sense
like I don't think I will become that
person through the hardships
even if I love ping pong I also love
cake I don't eat cake all day
that makes sense it does it makes sense
yeah okay all right do you have a strict
diet you stick to no I used to I counted
my macros for like 11 years really
because I was really fat and so I was
afraid of getting fat again how did you
how did you get fat to begin with was it
was it just something that
you know just excessive eating not
exercise I mean I'm curious or yeah yeah
okay well it's like people like when you
get fat I'm like eight months
some of it I feel like could be
hereditary calories some of it could be
hereditary I don't know I'm not I'm not
on it yeah that's kind of today with my
questions
yeah I inherited their bad habits of
food it could be well okay then that
yeah but people love that excuse no I
mean my family you know my mother was
Southern my dad was Iranian like
probably didn't have the best food in
the house but like I mean I let myself
go I think you know probably when I was
like
my upper teens it was bad I just drank a
ton and then would eat out and I was
just being irresponsible and I think
just for that period of time it's almost
like we didn't get out of high school
and it's like oh my God I'm free like
that's how I felt at least like not
being under the roof of my parents like
finally being free I was like oh my God
and then I just disregarded everything
that I had been doing and kind of who I
was and I that's when I gained more
weight
um and I went from like you know having
some weight to like
I was fat
um and when you say drinking you take
the alcohol oh yeah okay lots of alcohol
and that has a ton of calories I don't
think people think about that how did
you move out at 18 you don't see a lot
of people just moving out at 18. oh
unless they're going out to college okay
so I went and lived in the dorms got it
yeah one thing that's kind of
interesting to me is when I see people
that are like exceptional in what they
do I always wonder what is the main
driving factor of being this obviously
it has to be something maybe from
childhood or growing up but you were
saying when you were in college you
we're okay with college like you didn't
love it or anything but all the while
you were reading Tony Robbins books
right and trying to like develop your
yourself right yeah what do you think it
is in your life that caused you to have
this this drive to be exceptional is it
something that like your value your
parents instilled in you is it just a
unique thing that maybe is just like 10
of people have it or what causes you to
have this I think where it started and
where it comes from now are different so
I think where it started from was
um you know my parents ended up being
divorced when I was like I don't
remember eight or nine
um and then I end up living with my
mother who then became an alcoholic and
like went super down that rabbit hole um
and I essentially didn't want to tell
anybody because I was I didn't you know
it's like it's so funny to say it's like
I love my dad so much now and he's we're
really close but um I didn't know him
super well back then like I felt like he
was always at work and such so they got
divorced I didn't want to live with him
um and so I was instead with my mother
and I didn't want to tell anyone that
she had all these issues and she would
like leave me at home for long periods
of time and wouldn't come back and then
she would be in the hospital and then
she was like I remember one time she was
just like passed out on the driveway and
like the police came because the
neighbors called like just crazy [ __ ]
like that right and so I essentially had
to raise myself until I was 15 when she
tried to kill herself and I called the
cops and they came and then they said
you can't live with her anymore and so
they took me to my dad and then he was
like what's been going on I was like
all of this and so I told him and so I
think a lot of it was
looking at her as a person and seeing
like I was like how do you do that to
your kid one I'm like how do you like
become the mother that like becomes this
like crazy alcoholic and like
you know exposes your kid to all this
stuff and leaves them for weeks at a
time when they're young you know aren't
taking care of themselves and I just
wanted to be the opposite of that like I
was like I will I actually remember the
moment when I was sitting in the guest
room of my my mother's house and she
like hadn't come home for like three
days and I was calling her again and I
was like [ __ ] is she dead like and that
I always just assumed I'm like one time
I'm gonna call him she's just gonna be
dead or something and I hung up the
phone because she didn't answer for like
the 18th time and I was like screw this
and I was like I'm not going to be some
victim sitting here calling her waiting
for her to come home I was like I'm
gonna use this I'm gonna make my life
[ __ ] awesome like she has because she
would always tell me she's like well I
had a really bad childhood and all this
[ __ ] and I was like dude so you and 50
million other people on this Earth and
so I think looking at it I was just like
I will not be a victim of the
circumstance I will instead allow this
to be a reason why I succeed and this
will Propel me to my success and I
remember thinking that and I was like
and I'm going to help other people do
the same and see that circumstances
should not dictate how your life turns
out and it was in that moment that I was
like I want to invest in myself when I
started looking at Tony Robbins numero
and all that stuff you know when I found
them years later but it was often a lot
of not wanting to be like her
um and seeing and then noticing the
pattern in like so many women that they
didn't take care of themselves they
couldn't take care of themselves they
always relied on men
um I think I almost like to extend like
had a distaste for people like that
which I don't anymore which I'm glad
about
um but I really deeply never wanted to
rely on someone else and I never wanted
to be a victim of circumstance and I
think it was just watching her just do
that over and over again and seeing what
it turned into her life and I just I
felt very sad for her and that was what
put me in that direction
I no longer feel that that's what's
propelling me because I feel like it's
like I am obviously not that what
propels me now is more of a desire to
honestly just meet my future self and
see what's possible like I think
that we're all made of the same stuff
right and so it's like I can literally
do I I truly like I could do anything
that anyone else's worth has done and I
think that's really freaking cool and so
now it's more of a desire to see what
that looks like and to meet the person I
have to become
in 20 or 30 years when I put myself in
situations where there's more pressure
to become that kind of person so I like
putting myself in a business and setting
very high goals because there's external
circumstance that is forcing internal
change in order to make this successful
make the external successful the
business I have to become a different
person and I like that because I think
that's constant Challenge and so I think
it shifted over time I think when I was
probably around like 19 or 20 I went
from not wanting to be like her or be
like anyone like that to wanting
something more probably because I think
I went through a lot of like dealing
with it around that age because I was
very angry for a long time like I was
just angry about the situation and I
changed my mindset around it I was like
I am so and I really like I am deeply
thankful for this situation I am deeply
thankful that that happened because I
think I would have been so soft to have
that not happen like my my parents were
very protective of me as a kid and until
they got divorced I was in that
situation with her I think that they
probably would have continued to be very
protective of me and I don't know if I
would have learned how to lead myself
learned how to manage myself learn how
to manage my emotions had I not been
exposed to it young and I think getting
exposed to it Young
um it was a huge advance for me because
a lot of people are like how old are you
and like have you T I'm like I think I
started being able to parent myself and
manage myself at a very young age and so
it's helped me now that's interesting so
basically it was a a slow Decline and
then you apparently had to hit this Rock
Bottom moment in order to flip that
light switch and change I guess your I
don't know the way that you felt about
success in your own life yeah I think I
just realized that you know I forgave
her
um for everything that it went through I
mean I just look at it from a very
unbiased point of view I'm like she's
just a human and like so many people on
this Earth have so many issues and they
don't know how to deal with them and she
was not equipped with those tools and
she didn't have access to some of the
things I have access to now so she never
dealt with that stuff and she's just
I don't know chosen to never do anything
about it now so I don't know I think it
was just like dealing with that and
being like I'm okay with that and I'm
actually like really glad because I
realized probably around that age I was
like all of what I got to see showed me
so much about what I did want because I
knew what I didn't want I was like I
definitely don't want that and so I was
like what I do want looks more like this
and then over time it became a lot less
of I don't want that and more just this
is what I do want I've seen that a lot
where people they grow up in an
environment like they they see their
parents life and like I do not want that
for myself and that's a really powerful
motivator is to not be like someone also
in the same way of like being like
someone or being better than someone not
being like someone's also extremely
powerful yeah absolutely do you want
kids
not right now okay no
um
I think that
a lot of women want children when they
don't feel fulfilled by other areas of
their life and typically that's like in
your young 20s you're not fulfilled yet
you haven't figured out what you wanted
um and typically you know men are more
apt to like have pursued their career
earlier I started pursuing my career
fairly early and so the opportunity for
me to really feel a gap where a children
would feel it it just like never
occurred and so I think
um I would love if I had a kid with Alex
like I think the one thing is like oh I
would love to have a kid with him
specifically right like us have like a
little shared things like well it's half
of you
like very cute I don't think I would
enjoy the day-to-day as much as I enjoy
the day today of what I do now without
kids
so one thing Alex mentioned about having
a kid is that he says it could be a
selfish thing to have a kid because a
lot of people are selfish insofar as
like they want to see their kid they
want to see that kid as me that gives a
representation of me and I like me so I
love my kid what do you think about that
I agree with him really what do you
think
explain it it's selfish it's usually
motivated by being selfish
because like people he says people can
oftentimes be inherently selfish like
some people a lot of people uh and
that's like the motivation of having a
kid You could argue both ways I feel
like you could say that's one of the
most unselfish things because then you
put your child before you or you would
you would hope that would be the case
but then you dedicate you know so much
of your like you could be spending your
time doing anything else but now you're
taking care of another person like
raising another person that person
becomes a priority I think it could go
either way but it could be done
initially at a selfish selfish reasons
maybe maybe you're unfulfilled or maybe
it's something to replace like you know
I don't feel purpose but now with the
child I feel purpose yes so it could go
both ways I feel I think most people
have a kid to give themselves purpose
and then they put a lot of
pressure onto the child to fulfill the
purpose that they've desired and so that
kid has all this pressure on them from a
parent that's not warranted and the kid
never wanted that pressure right but
it's what the parent has wanted from the
kid and so I think a lot of times they
try to project it's almost like using it
as like a projection of oneself
and so I think in those situations it
doesn't make sense to have a kid
and I mean like I mean I don't know
about you but like I mean I would like
my I'm not yet enough of a realized
person to want to have a kid and be like
I'm okay if Johnny Hates Me and is
unsuccessful because here's the thing he
could hate you and be an unsuccessful
person you could have a kid and they
could be a piece of [ __ ] and they could
hate you and like never do anything with
their lives and you have to be okay with
that I was in a room with Tony Robbins
just like a month ago and he literally
talked about this he's like dude you
have got to be okay with the fact that
if you have a kid who's talking to some
woman he's like that that kid might not
be successful at all and might not like
you
do you still want to have a kid
that's worst case scenario can you live
with the worst case scenario that is
worst case scenario
that's exactly what Alex said Alex well
this is what Alex said he says uh he
would have a hard time saying that he
wants them to be their own person she
would want them to be who he wants them
to be yeah he would yeah I mean I'll
agree with say that same thing I mean I
yeah I'd have a very it would obviously
hurt as a parent it's like you try so
hard to like raise your kid to be moral
or ethical you know what I mean yeah and
then all of a sudden they're like I'm
not gonna say anything but doing bad
stuff you know yeah I'm so worried with
the kids tend to rebel and if like I'm
so focused on like you know hey
improving yourself and making money and
growing and like you know fulfilling
your passion and they're like Ah that's
stupid because Dad does it I'm just
gonna go smoke weed and like that's all
they do I'd be so upset
I just feel like the best parenting
strategy is leading by example like
obviously there are some times where
you're gonna have to step in you know
tell your kid no don't do that don't do
that but for the most part like I feel
like people are moral and they know when
they did something wrong for the most
part and if you're always just a good
person your kid will see that they'll
respect it you know what I mean will
they yeah because kids will always be
betrayed by their friends there will
always be an ebb and flow to
relationships with their peers right but
if you can be this fatherly figure that
the kid can always look up to and be
like there is no ebb and flow to my dad
he's always been good to me he always
loves me he always supports me in all of
my actions and you just live your own
life and lead by example there's no ebb
and flow to that they're constant
yeah I don't agree I think it just
depends on the kid I mean I've seen the
same but then humans have this natural
proclivity to rebel and so it's like if
you set the standard even if you're not
trying to coerce someone into an action
they know when you're trying to
influence them and humans naturally
Rebel when they think that they're under
influence which is why so many kids
rebel against their parents there's lots
of studies on this so I think it depends
on the intelligence level of the kid
like I could look at my parents when I
was a kid and be like my dad does this
that's good right so I think some kids
100 that is and let's be real it's
better to lead by example than not yes
it's just that when they're of a certain
age when they're very like they're very
drawn to that Rebellion stage that they
just do the opposite but the thing is it
usually is like an echo chamber for
example your kid Rebels and then you get
mad at your kid and the kid's like oh
well this is the worst thing that's
going to happen is they're going to get
mad at me like that's pretty bad but I
can deal with that instead of like just
I feel like letting it kind of happen as
long as it's not like outside of what
you deem okay and then obviously being
upset by it but like not like shunning
your kid and like pointing fingers and
stuff like that yeah well that's I think
most people don't understand how to use
punishment and that punishment actually
is not useful most of the time why do
you think punishment's not useful
because what is punishment actually
doing like are they learning anything
from if the goal is that they don't do
this thing again then now what you're
teaching them is that you get this this
bad thing happens when you've done a bad
thing but you're not teaching them how
to be better you're not helping them
realize for themselves why they could do
something differently the next time and
it's not autonomous either it's you are
an external person
you know inflicting a punishment upon
them versus like them deciding for
themselves that it's not a good idea so
I feel like it just takes away a lot of
autonomy it's kind of like if an
employee makes a mistake in my business
am I going to yell at them and be like
you did not do a good job and because of
this you're getting taken away and I'm
like no I am also a human who makes
mistakes I do not do that I put Jack and
timeout so many times yeah like Jack now
I know I hated it yeah part of me though
feels like it was a child within like a
certain range of activities that they
could be doing it's like putting on a
timeout or something negative moves them
away from that pain and so they're like
well if I don't scream at the restaurant
I I don't have to go and sit by myself
for 30 minutes with nothing to do and so
then you could learn social cues by like
I don't want to be in timeout so I'm not
going to do that long enough for you to
like recognize that that's not something
to do I agree to an extent it's just
that most children then find a way to
just avoid the punishment so they'll
just figure out a way to do it without
you finding out as the parent
so they're not taught to not do the
thing they're taught to know now if I do
the thing I get punished and now I have
to figure out how to avoid that
punishment maybe yeah I can't say yeah
yeah
I think I have a very very similar
Viewpoint and
um when I grew up and I went to school I
went to to two completely opposite
schools one was in a you know very
impoverished area and was one was very
wealthy and I learned that at this
wealthy school
um a lot of the kids have great examples
for parents right they have parents that
have successful careers uh half the time
you know it's like a whole family or
whatever you want to call it and I
noticed that those kids
um would Rebel
probably more than than than the ones
over here and um I think that just
because if you lead by example doesn't
mean that your kid will want that I
think they're gonna want what they want
well there's a difference between
leading by example on and enabling
because I know that's a pretty big
stereotype it's like if you're a wealthy
parent you kind of enable your kid to do
these bad things because you can always
get them out of trouble and I think that
is also kind of like it's like the
opposite of punishment right enabling
kinda
it's like they're both the the extremes
on the Spectrum Alex made a reference
about the two types of relationships
that in his mind he thinks work so one
is the we are in this together
relationship where two people are you
know split Partners split
responsibilities he said so that's what
you and him are
um and then the other one is the
cheerleader and the quarterback with the
cheerleader cheering on the quarterback
and um that's not as successful of a
dynamic as we are in this together what
do you think about that are those the
two real only dynamics that you think
will work and do you agree that we are
in this together is the most powerful
Dynamic for a successful relationship
yeah I mean
I I actually there's a study that's been
done that basically talks about the
three dynamics of relationship and who's
the happiest versus who's the most
successful versus who's not right so the
most successful and the ones that make
the most money are the ones that have
our Dynamic where it's two people that
share the power that are in the same
vehicle together that are driving
towards something right so they have a
shared career uh they're in it together
and they split it and it's equal power
right they make the most money but
they're not the most content they're
happy but they're not the most content
the most content are actually people who
they each have their own individual
career which is similar but separate
right
um but they're both like leading the way
in those careers and then the last one
are the people who are the most content
but make the least amount of money and
impact which is uh one person is the
dominating force and the other person is
like the assistant or supporter
um more content for sure uh less money
and impact so there's a study done
Esther perel broke down basically talked
about those three so I think what he was
pointing out was basically just like
there's a couple things which is like
that's what we see most commonly and
this is like speaking in generalization
so like I see those tend to work best
also because it's Clarity of roles right
like it's really clear that either
you're in this together or it's like one
person's doing it the other one's
following
I think a lot of people if you go
outside of that then you have to Define
it for yourself so I'd say other forms
of relationships could absolutely be
successful it's just that most people
don't clarify it like most people don't
clarify what our relationship is what
are the rules of this relationship game
and if we're not picking one that's off
the shelf what's it going to be and a
lot of people don't take the time to
decide like are you a want match for me
like is what I want and what you want
are they the same thing and are we going
to write it down and make it very clear
because I think that's where most people
go wrong and that's why it's in both
those scenarios it's so well defined
that it's almost it's hard to argue that
makes sense yeah so I do think that that
is probably I agree with what he's
saying we talk about a lot because we're
like we also recognize that like our
relationship is not like most and it's I
think it's honestly just a unique
situation in which like we met under
weird circumstances we're both kind of
odd people and like have different you
know things that we're like interested
in um and we just work and I don't think
that our relationship advice should
apply to everybody like at all in fact I
think it applies to less people it's
like if you put two people in the same
room think about this right like if you
go on a deserted island with somebody
it's like and you're stuck there for
like a month
you most likely will love that person at
the end of that month whether you want
to or not whether you even like them or
not you may love them because it's
almost like a feeling of comfort and so
I think that it's it's just reminding
ourselves like feelings are always going
to be fleeing if we have a good argument
and a good foundation for the marriage
that's logical then it's more likely to
last in the long run and so it's also I
guess you know it'd be like what is your
goal some people don't care about being
married forever or like for the rest of
their lives and like a lot of people
don't I know a lot of people are like
Layla I don't dive with that and so I'm
also speaking in terms of like if you
want to be married for a long time I've
done a lot of research on that I've read
a lot about it and I feel pretty
strongly that that I'm going to be right
do you have any dating advice for Jack
are you dating
um
I'm trying to be dating yeah what's that
mean how are you trying because I'm not
really like like I feel like in order to
qualify as dating you probably need to
be going on dates okay then you're
trying to go on dates but you're not uh
uh I wouldn't say I'm like
trying super hard to go on dates but if
the opportunity presented you know then
I'd probably go on a date yeah that's
gonna be hard you're gonna be waiting a
long time yeah I think realistically I
just need more urgency with it you know
how old are you 23. oh you're young yeah
I need to be more motivated my Alex I
was 23. really
all right I gotta get on it
but I don't really spend much time on
him to be honest like I like I said
there's an ebb and flow to my motivation
with dating sometimes I really want a
girlfriend sometimes I don't I I figure
if there is an ebb and flow like that
probably means it's not the right time
so I think that's normal actually okay
maybe it is perfect maybe it's the
perfect time I mean there's totally
times when you're gonna be in a
relationship and you'll be like I could
be totally fine being single yeah yeah
that's me and Alex actually talk about
that we're like yeah if you died I don't
know if I get remarried you probably
would right no you wouldn't dude that's
like I feel like I'm like the worst like
I would have a lot of money and like run
this big business and like have had a
husband that I like ran it with who then
you know died it's like who's my
candidate pool like younger guys like I
feel like a lot of men don't like the
fact that I want all these things for
myself and I have these Ambitions or I
find someone who's like a complete beta
and they're like yeah sure I'll like
flying a private jet and take all your
money and do all that which I wouldn't
marry that person because I would
definitely not want them to take all my
money so it's like what purpose does
marriage sure it's like it's like I
don't know if it would serve a purpose
at that point you could always have a
life partner or someone that you're with
yeah you know what I mean yeah because
at that point I just feel like and then
I don't know I mean Alex is always like
I was [ __ ] together what it wasn't
built together if you get a new person
right yeah it wasn't built together and
I and then at a certain point you're
like
because I think the reason that people
get married get married changes right
it's like a lot of people get married to
have kids together and start a family
there's always like a purpose behind it
right
um and I think some people get married
you know we got married because we
wanted to build this life together right
and so it's like if I have built the
life that I've wanted and say I don't
have kids and don't want kids and then
I'm 45 and you know Alex is no longer
there why would I get married and it
would probably be if I wanted to start
some kind of new life or new something
with somebody but if I'm content in my
own then yeah I don't know why I'd get
married that makes sense there is a
possibility you seem very set in your
ways like about how you are so excited
to meet your future self right there is
a chance that one day you wake up and
all of your your desires from that just
completely change into something like I
want to live on a ranch in Montana
there's a chance right yeah and so what
if the right guy comes along you know
he's a plumber he's fixing your pipes
you're assuming Alex is dead assuming
conversation but there's a chance
something like that can happen right do
you think there's a chance
it's still weird a lot of assumptions
have to happen there Jack
but like if this happens if that happens
and then over here
which is I think if I look at like who I
was when I was even two years old versus
who I am now I think there's always been
an inherent like I've always been
someone who's pursued challenges in that
way I don't plan on stopping and maybe I
do wake up and one day you know I mean
this is the thing though it's like
there's plenty of days I feel like doing
that that like hey we could just retire
and get a ranch and do it like of course
there's days where that sounds like more
incentivizing I just never have given
into that feeling so I would have to
change a lot as a human in order to do
that I don't feel like it I'm not going
on some Ayahuasca trip anytime soon
which is one I've seen a lot of people
you know they do some weird thing like
that and then they're like oop other way
yeah um yeah what are your thoughts on
like psychedelics
Ayahuasca have you have you tried any of
that I'm just curious no no I've done a
lot of drugs like in my past but like
not like the hippie drugs like hard
drugs okay
um so I don't even know how to define it
yeah but I feel like is a difference of
hard drugs yeah
like the you know I haven't done like
meth or anything but okay
let's be clear during my partying phase
like I try I was like sure I'll try
something like I was just super
irresponsible I didn't think about
consequences
um but I've not like since that phase I
haven't done drugs just because what I'm
thinking are you thinking what I'm
thinking what the meth
what we had a guy on the podcast a long
time ago
former addict oh and he talked about
meth Jack's question was how do you do
it
[Laughter]
you have an alcoholic and you're like
what was your favorite drink can you
decide it was Jake it was Jake it was
Jake I read the room and he said he was
comfortable he was comfortable and I
really had no idea you know it was an
itch I wanted to scratch it so I asked
the question I actually love that right
it's like what do you do it right I
don't want to say a certain ways to that
I think it can be done but what do you
do I mean I asked we met a guy and he
was like I have two wives and I was like
tell me how that works like you know
it's just satisfying that random you
know little curiosity I just think you
could have Googled that like that wasn't
I wanted nothing he specifically did it
man him yes I wanted to know you know oh
my god did he describe it I don't think
he did no because he wouldn't let him
I didn't think it was appropriate for
the podcast
describe how this guy you know that's
that's a good point yeah because you
don't want to like yeah yeah you don't
want to teach people how to no do you
guys do psychedelics no I've I've never
done anything uh I'll incriminate myself
here I've I've tried weed like three
times in my entire life and that was it
and I hated it every single time the
first time I was 16 and I was hanging
out like in the band group and all of
them were Stoners yeah and so I would
see them doing it I was like I was just
curious I'm like what what's appealing
about this I never had any desire
something I'm gonna try it and hated it
instantaneously like I didn't like that
feeling of not being in control I felt
paranoid I was like I thought the police
were going to show up and just like
arrest all of us I hated it but then
they're like no you got you gotta do it
again because like the first time is
never good like the second time I tried
again it was hated to just as much and I
think there was a third time years later
where where I was like maybe I hated it
there's not one point I ever enjoyed it
so now that was my only ever experience
okay
yeah I'm not really like a proponent I
think most people like oh it opens up my
brain it makes me smarter and I'm like
it literally turns off part of your
brain I don't really think that makes
you smarter but like I don't think like
if you really study what they do they
turn off different parts of the brains
and then people like I can make better
decisions I'm like can you though
the argument is that with certain parts
of your brain shut off you can kind of
isolate your focus to other parts of
your brain and it kind of simplifies
things yeah do I necessarily agree that
like it's a good strategy to find
Clarity no but can it be used as a tool
to find Clarity probably yeah I've
always been curious about like being
able to tap into different senses of
like creativity or different thoughts
that you would never have otherwise but
then it's like I would never want to
like alter myself in such a way where
you would rely on that or maybe like
that's the only way you could tap into
that and I've been so terrified of doing
anything because I'm like if I if I like
it it would be hard for me not to
justify continuing so it's probably best
I just don't I mean I think that's a
really sound strategy that's basically
how I operate which is like I would
probably like it and so I do not want to
try it like I tried things in my past
and I liked them and I was like I do not
try like you try like and even like
stuff like Adderall I'm like oh my God I
really like Adderall not doing that
again you know like it's just I just
don't want to even risk it yeah I think
for me I limit it just a coffee
a coffee's the perfect balance it is
addictive it is incredibly addictive and
you kind of rely on it yeah I couldn't
go a day without the problem how much do
you drink uh usually two cups of coffee
which it's not bad but conservative
Graham it's not three I how how many
cups of coffee do you see around the
house that are half finished is that
coffee I see no this is way too many to
be two cups a day man no because I don't
pick up the glasses that could be glass
from like days ago
that's a different problem man if you're
like what leaving glass so sometimes
I'll just I'll have a coffee like this
we picked three glasses from the podcast
let's leave it and then it gets watered
down two cups of coffee so now two cups
it's not three I know 100 is not three
now that you rely on coffee right yeah
how bad is it that you drink it every
day if you could find something else
that was as inconvenient to drink his
coffee but it was it had the amount of
upside that coffee does it was just
another random thing let's just say
terrible example smoking a cigarette
okay but there wasn't really like the
health detriment of smoking it would you
step outside and smoke a couple
cigarettes per day if you got the same
amount of benefit of coffee no probably
not no for me for me the coffee is like
I really enjoy the taste I like sipping
on something I like a cold drink and I
never drink warm coffee it's about
having a like a cold drink over ice but
something about it enjoys the taste of
menthol
what if I enjoyed anything else I mean
what does that have to do with Menthol
you guys think coffee's bad
I don't think coffee's bad I think that
the logic you're using is a touch flawed
you know because you're two cups a day
check we get Macy in here she'll tell me
okay that's the point here but you know
the the coffee consumption you rely on
it Everything I Do I Do rely on it right
and if you want to have if you wouldn't
have it right wouldn't you feel poorly
correct yeah but if you just think I've
gone off coffee multiple times do you
feel like [ __ ] for like a few days and
then you're fine yeah I know it's better
when you have it yeah yeah I've the last
time I think it was like 2018 it's like
five years ago that I I stopped drinking
coffee for like a month and I found
myself I was less happy I was not
motivated and I made less money
and like immediately when that happened
I was like let me just drink coffee like
something important part's not you know
it's no big deal but the money party the
money yes but no I just I lost that
sense of enjoyment it was weird like the
first two weeks sucked and that was like
it was just going to bed early and just
you know tired groggy in the morning but
after like three weeks it kind of wore
off I kind of my my mood and my energy
was about the same but I just lacked
that like something to look forward to
and for me it was just like I looked
forward to having that cup of coffee I
don't know what it is why did you take a
month off uh I wanted to see if I could
do it and I read something online I
watched a YouTube video about being
addicted to caffeine and uh maybe it was
like ASAP science or something of of
your body on caffeine they mentioned
that it was like 20 days or something
like that that your body gets rid of it
and like because you built up such a
tolerance to it I just figured it's
probably a healthy thing to do
I mean people they've done studies on
this it's like one cup of coffee a day
those people live longer and are happier
on average yeah but they say that about
cause or correlation I don't know yeah
but like I think it's dosage like most
things like did you know if you smoke a
cigarette three times a week
doesn't really do [ __ ] like people don't
talk about that they're not like you can
only smoke three weeks and stuff like
smoking is so bad for you but like if
you smoked three a week you most likely
would never have anything yeah but don't
you think if you smoked three a week
that it would be very easy to for that
person to want four but then yeah
correct sure but if you have
self-control or discipline if you're
somebody that can actually do that which
I know people who are like they'll smoke
a cigarette once a week or every two
weeks or whatever and you know that they
know all these things
um they're like that's not bad but it's
it's the Habit that gets people into it
so you can't stop I mean it's like
anything in life right if we have too
much of it it's probably not gonna be
good I watched a good video uh from yes
Theory where they visited the country
that lives the longest and for them it
was wine and they would be drinking a
lot of wine it was like two to three
glasses a day of wine but it seemed to
be more of the lifestyle that it's a lot
of socializing and a lot of just like a
community aspect right than a small town
and they're all like drinking wine
together and it seems like that's
probably better for you than the wine
itself I would think so but communal
aspect of it yeah I mean like America
doesn't have much of that at all no oh
in their work schedule I think was uh
like three days or four days like they
had a much different schedule I forget
where this was it was a really good
video that's interesting yeah yeah there
was another channel that uh got
recommended so what is it skylife Where
She interviewed some of the oldest
living people and tried to figure out
their secrets and a lot of it was having
purpose work uh but for them it was um
their church and like staying alive long
enough to you know spread the gospel and
and network with other people Network
it's a network but but had that
supportive Community where they're all
like aligned together and and oh you
know what it was it was uh part of their
religion was very much about like no
caffeine no drinking no smoking all
natural foods and I think that really
fed into it
who knows
that's the thing yeah is there anything
you wanted to bring up or talk about
here I was going to ask you guys what
your goals are right now
that was my next question just like
what's the goal in terms of like with
iced coffee hour versus the you know the
main Channel like what are you guys
focused on right now uh main channel for
me is always like the top of the the top
of the totem pole it's about to say
pyramid
I can't you can't say pyramid anymore
without making it sound like a scam scam
I've basically just gotten to a point
where I really feel like I should be
diversifying and trying different things
and not just having you know the the
main Channel which has basically been my
core for such a long time and I know
that I cannot sustain three videos a
week indefinitely there's got to be a
point where eventually I'm going to
scale down to two maybe there's gonna be
one
um or maybe it's just you know just five
years from now I'm like yeah yeah I
don't want to continue uh making those
videos who knows but I want to have
other things that I could do in
conjunction with that main Channel
um so it started off as a second Channel
which was the reaction videos we've done
the iced coffee hour which I believe has
probably the most longevity from
anything
right but then it's like you don't want
to just be uh you know on camera all the
time and I felt like Creator properties
would be a great way where I could
continue focusing on all the other
channels which are my priority right now
while still investing and getting back
to the roots of real estate what is
Creator properties so it's a syndication
where we could team up with other
accredited investors and buy a property
that is significantly bigger than I
would be able to do on my own and Ryan
Pineda has such a tight team that's able
to handle all of the day-to-day and so
that's where the benefit really came in
the sense that you know I could invest
my money into this and get exposure to
deals that I wouldn't have done on my
own because I just I wouldn't have the
time to find them I wouldn't have the
time to manage them so much work that
goes on behind the scenes in terms of
like fixing up and remodeling I couldn't
do that and it's it would pull time away
from everything else that I'm doing so
you put your money in there and then how
do you find the other people to you know
put capital in just our own network
um whether that be just putting a link
in the description I've talked about it
every now and then Ryan talked about it
when he was on the podcast uh I found so
far that usually just placing a link in
the description I don't like to be too
pitchy yeah and so I'm I'm always afraid
like hey guys you know go and sign up
and oh you know it's expiring in 30 days
and you got to do it now like I I just
don't feel good about that um so usually
it's just I I feel better just putting a
link in the description I'll casually
mention it and that's and that's it I
feel like the people who are interested
are more likely to do that anyway then
yeah like having it forced so typical
you know what's the minimum that someone
has to put into one of those deals it
depends on the deal uh it's gonna be
between probably 25 and 75 000 oh [ __ ]
it's a lot well that makes sense too
because I was thinking like for your
channel like if it's like 500 Grand or
something no yeah yeah okay no
um yeah the first deal uh was 25 and I
think going forward it's going to be
higher
um but a lot of the other ones that I've
heard uh some of the biggest ones are uh
250 to 350 Grand yeah and like they
won't take anyone lower than that and
that's like the standard they've set and
uh they get it yeah so I think for this
first one we really just wanted to test
a proof of concept and we felt like you
know 25 was an appropriate amount yeah
that makes sense as long as it's just
somebody that 25 is not much money it's
not hard to do that it's not like a lot
of pressure on you guys right that's
interesting so do you want to do more
things like that is that what the goal
is I think the goal is to get to do that
in conjunction with everything else I
mean right now my goal is just to
continue focusing on Main second podcast
channels have you guys thought about
creating your own product I'm not a
product person I mean I I've wasted so
much just
energy and mental thoughts on like oh I
should be doing this and you know when
Alex was here he got me thinking like oh
man what am I doing my strength and my
enjoyment comes from making videos and
so right now that should be my focus I
think anything else I'm not that person
I'm I love just getting down planning
out a video scripting filming
title thumbnail like that that's what I
like doing and that's I think my
strength yeah I think you should do that
I guess I just like from my perspective
right like like there's so many people
that just want to work with somebody
like you and build the business below it
and like not bother you with any of it
but they could I don't know
I I I get my fingers and everything it's
hard for me to just now it's really hard
for me to take a a backseat approach and
just let someone else handle it it's
really difficult
um if I see something I'm like no it
should be done this way and I I get two
you know nitpicky with things so I've
kind of realized that limitations just
yeah yeah and attaching my name to
anything I would be a perfectionist in
that knowing that if something goes bad
then
I would obsess over how could I fix that
that would be hard to scale something
then yeah that makes sense yeah main
focus is just the ice coffee hour for
sure and growing and having the best
possible guests on talking about the
coolest possible stuff and I don't know
making the best content do you see
something that Graham doesn't see in
terms of like where there's potential
for the business oh yeah
yes certainly I'm I'm like very much so
like hey let's keep like trying out new
things uh like hiring on more people
building building and Graham is very
much like what we're doing right now is
working let's just continue doing it and
if we continue doing that we'll continue
moving up so but I like I think maybe
I'm a little bit more risky you know and
uh I want to try out more things that
maybe are a little bit more exhausting
such as potentially hiring someone and
you know doing stuff like that but
interesting I think both are needed
though so that's a good deal yeah it's
just like most the time what you do is
needed and then every once in a while we
need a new idea so it's like how can you
in a safe environment continue to test
ideas that's like low risk low capital
and then when one does work then you're
like I like that too then yeah I think
for me and the iced coffee hour the
biggest thing is how can we break out of
our
I don't want to call it a rut but right
now our the guests that we have on is
within our sphere of influence and it's
people that we know or or people that
we've reached out to or get back to us
or who want to come on uh there's plenty
of people like that but we want to get
into just musicians actors uh people
that we would never ordinarily come in
contact with through the YouTube space
and
we're having a hard time doing that
because we look at let's say podcasts
like uh nelk or impulsive and they're
getting some of these people like how I
can't believe it like Nel got the
president on or the former president
Trump
um and like I'm not expecting that we
would get a you know president on but
some of the people that they're on I'm
like oh my gosh how did they do that
that's incredible
um and I think we need to break into
that do you know those people like of
the podcast impulsive could you talk to
them uh no I mean I watched their
podcast I watched almost every single
one of them yeah because I feel like the
fastest way is actually not to go figure
out how to get the influencers or like
the celebrities or the musicians or any
of that stuff it'd be to go to the
people that have those podcasts and say
how do you get these people on your show
they literally just DM them I mean Logan
Paul has 20 million followers yeah
Instagram so it's like he DMS anybody
they see it that's interesting right
yeah so have you tried dming and they
shouldn't respond yeah we we would send
out I mean
Jack's like Jack is like a DM Celine
Dion DM Bruno Mars like Jack you're
never gonna get back to us what we used
to do is and we'd come up with a list of
like 20 possible people we could bring
on the podcast then you know create a
copy paste should I say copy paste it
wasn't quite a template but I would go
through and personalize every single one
of them yeah and we would send this out
to those 20 people that we created the
list of and then I did it one recently I
thought it was funny because I looked up
you know mainstream celebrities in Las
Vegas and sure Celine Dion was on the
list sure Bruno Mars was on the list but
if you don't shoot you can't make it
yeah the thing I think with a lot of
those people is that they have large PR
teams that they just can't come on and
talk candidly on a podcast without a lot
of review and approval ahead of time
because anything they say could reflect
on so many different Avenues as soon as
you land one though then you can use
that to land because I've I've actually
encountered this several times where
people like all right show me the best
episodes you've had or the coolest
people you've had on I've had to like
send this out to people for trying to
get someone on
um so that's very common yeah I know
like Steve Aoki lives here in like you
know what's going on with that man I've
told you I know I feel like I know
people who are like friends with him
here I'm like I feel like he would come
on yeah yeah there was a point where uh
it was like you know covet time and and
didn't feel comfortable with uh you know
coming on at that point yeah with
everything he was doing so yeah I gotta
reach back out yeah you should reach
back out I feel like that's a great one
yeah especially because I don't think
people know that he's like such a great
business person yeah and they're just
like oh Stephen okay the DJ I'm like no
dude he's like Savage Oh Yeah
that's sick yeah so yeah I think he's
just breaking into that yeah I was
actually doing some thinking I think it
would be a smart idea we hire a podcast
producer for three months
I really like that idea I love it for
three I think it's a great just three
months yeah and if we don't see a
benefit in three months that's the end
of it I agree and there's 90 days they
have 90 days you should just totally
like if you're ever trying to like hire
somebody and it's like it just bring
someone as a contractor say it's a
project basis and we'll reevaluate in 90
days yeah part of part of the thing for
me is that I feel like I've done
everything myself and I'm like we could
just do it we have four people between
us and Andrew four people there's no
reason why we can't accomplish that but
well not everyone's you though yeah but
I feel like everyone has the time this
is the fallacy that most Founders like
you have when you're like a very capable
person is you think that it takes
everyone else the same time it takes you
and that's the reason a lot of
businesses can't grow is people like
well I'm not gonna hire someone because
like Sally can do that for two they
don't have the attention yeah most
people don't have the attention to do
what you do and have that much dedicated
like most people have so many other
things going on in their lives I mean to
get myself out of the business it's
probably like five to six rolls that
need to get hired that are high level
people that are paid like you know
between 200 and 500 Grand a year each to
get Alex out of the business it's
usually like you know eight to ten
people to get them out to like build a
whole marketing department basically so
it's like it just never you're never
gonna find like one person who's gonna
be able to do it as well as you
and most teams it's something you're
good at okay something you're bad at
you'll for sure find people that are
better than you at it because you're
like okay I don't think that we're
particularly good at reaching out to
guests because that's something that
lies in your court of like the
responsibilities of this people right
and I would say honestly that's one of
the things that we need the most amount
of at least I would get someone I would
pay them a commission based on the
guests that they're going to get so you
basically like an A List bless c-list
guest and they get paid a commission
based on the kind of guess that they
bring onto the show that's I literally
said that exact thing to you I said
exact thing yep you mentioned the
commission you never said a b and CNN
yes I know I I literally said they bring
on this tier we pay them x amount they
bring on this tier we pay them extra
money
full-time doing that that's going to get
you out of the rut 100 agree no I think
that is I think that is the main reason
we need a producer is for guest Outreach
I don't even think it's for the
production of the podcast I think that's
all going fine maybe it's not a producer
what would you call it because a
producer is gonna take the person that
you attracted it would help if they
greased up the machine that is the
podcast you know that's not going to
make the biggest difference and so if
you put out video producer 9 99.9 those
people can't do that so would it be like
an Asian or something I would have to
Google it for sure yeah to me it sounds
like you have like you build up some
sort of network of a couple people that
just kind of have contacts and um once
one of them finds somebody that would be
suitable for us then they get paid you
know like the fee yeah and it's
beneficial for them and for us is this
just a commission thing that so we just
put feelers out and we say maybe with
five people we'll pay you based on the
guests you bring in you could do five
people or if you pay one person ideally
that person has a network of people who
do what they do and then they'll just
pay those people if they really need
something and then they cover it with
their commission is it worth it to hire
somebody who maybe is just resourceful
like one person who does everything but
maybe they could you know find people
and network I will say this which is I
um work with a company that does
something similar and the guy is very
resourceful but it takes time to build a
network and so what you don't have is
that you have the time that you he's
undergoing to build that Network that
you have to pay for but if you can find
somebody who's already built that
Network then you don't have to pay for
that time you just pay for their
experience yeah and I mean I think I I
don't like waiting so I'm like I would
rather find somebody who has already
done it and already has a network
because building one takes time
that's just me though I like that what
do you think on that great idea because
I think we are under the mindset that we
have to hire someone full time for three
months no okay you can hire I mean you
can literally do whatever you want you
just have to be clear and set the
expectations to that person so like I
would just be clear when I'm putting a
wreck out there I'd be like I'm hiring
someone to get this product you have
three months and if you're able to hit
this goal which is maybe like two A-list
guests or something like that would you
want to bring them on full-time like
what would they have to do in those
first three months for you to say now I
would want to bring you on full time and
then you tell them that's what it is and
it's very clear and if they agree to it
and you agree to it then like it's great
works on both sides yeah
I agree let's do that okay cool yeah you
got to get this out by tomorrow I know
yeah keep going yeah well thank you so
much for coming out I really appreciate
it this has actually been really helpful
for us too yeah oh good yeah I
appreciate you guys having me cool well
thank you I'll link to all of your info
Down Below in the description uh where
you can also get a free stock and you
can follow me on Instagram
Alex just use the code Graham thank you
our sponsors did you just say for some
reason for some reason and with that
said you guys till next time it's time
perfect thank you thank you